Before we move on to creating
our own If statements,
let's look at a few examples.
To see these examples in action,
download the ifstatements.playground
file.
To see your results in the console,
go up to the View menu,
scroll down to Debug Area,
and click Show Debug Area.
You might see three errors there
at the top of the console.
Those are caused by
a bug in Playgrounds,
which will hopefully be fixed soon,
but you can ignore them for now.
Let's scroll down a little bit, and
first I want you to
focus here on Example 1.
Now, when I go up to the Editors menu,
and
I click Execute Playground,
nothing happens.
Now try changing the variable hungry
to true and see what happens.
Down here, we can see nom nom
printed out in the console.
Now let's focus on Example 2.
This time try changing the value of
the Bool wantTeddyBear to be true and
see what happens, and down here in
the console, we can see snuggle snuggle.
Moving on to Example 3,
see what happens when you change
the variable raining to equal true.
Again, you can see that a new message is
printed to the console, Ryan Gosling!
Be still my heart!
And notice that in each scenario
a different function is called.